(lively music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
It's been a while, it's been a few months,
so I'm really excited to be able to host
another great conversation.
And today I'm honored and
thrilled to be able to welcome
Joanne "Coach P" McCallie
to the Addy Hour podcast.
Coach P, thank you so much for being here,
definitely appreciate it.
- Thank you, it's always
great to be amongst a Dukie.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's always a good thing.
- Yep, definitely a good connection there.
And for me, I'll have
to contain my excitement
because as our listeners
know, I'm a Duke fan,
am a Duke fan, a Duke graduate,
so this is a full circle moment for me
to be able to host you
after watching you on the
sidelines for so many years.
I definitely appreciate just all the work
that you're doing as well.
- Thank you, thank you.
Great to be here, great to be here.
- Excellent, and by way of introduction,
I just want to give our listeners
a little bit of background
about who you are and what
you've been up to last few years.
But of course, that's
something we'll delve into
in the conversation as well.
But Joanne "Coach P" McCallie
is a former NCAA Division I
women's basketball coach,
a position that she held
for 28 years.
And as talks about, she's now taking on
her greatest role yet.
So she's foraging a path to
destigmatizing mental health
and coaching those afflicted
by mental health challenges
to pass for a full and productive life.
As I mentioned, Coach P has
a history as an elite coach,
and a champion.
She's led teams at Maine, Michigan State,
and most importantly, Duke, not really,
but from my perspective,
most importantly Duke.
Making National Coach of the Year
and winning numerous championships
at all three schools.
She's the only coach in history
to win Coach of the Year
and four different conferences,
and she achieved that five times.
She's also the only Division
I coach, head coach,
to lead two different
programs to 30 win seasons
and three National
Championship game appearances,
so someone who has obviously
excelled in her craft.
But she's also a winner in
life with a powerful story.
As someone who is diagnosed
with bipolar disorder
at the age of 30 while coaching at Maine,
it was something she wanted
to reveal for decades,
but she was counseled
otherwise because of concerns
that the consequences that
it might have for her career
and on her teams.
And even despite these
struggles she also had about
with skin cancer,
but still successfully raised a family
and continued to triumph in basketball.
But in 2021, she decided
it was time to shift
and to talk and become a mental
health advocate and speaker,
sharing her story to
inspire and educate others
on how to win without losing yourself.
The results of her work has
been a best selling book,
"Secret Warrior: A Coach and
Fighter, On and Off the Court"
something we'll talk about
a little bit more today.
And she's also the author
of "Choice Not Chance:
Rules for Building a Fierce Competitor".
So again, I'm just
deeply honored to be able
to host Coach P here.
I'm grateful for all the
work that you're doing
in these spaces.
And outside of even the
mental health component,
all the things that you
do around mentorship
is also something that's
very near and dear
to my heart personally,
and in my professional and academic roles.
So I'm sure there's lots
that we could talk about
on this podcast, but we
won't make the conversation
go too long, but I'm
just honored to be able
to welcome you here today.
- It's thrilling, I love it,
and I love the work that you do.
I admire work and brain health so much.
- Thanks so much.
- Yeah.
- Thanks so much, and in a sense,
I feel like the conversation
that we're having is,
these are the types of
things that have been
really gratifying for me,
even as a neuroscientist,
to be able to have these partnerships
and these conversations,
so that we don't just
get stuck in our silos
working and when we're
working in isolation,
when it has so much importance and impact
for our society in general.
So, I appreciate your willingness to come
and for us to be able to
engage that, to model it,
and hopefully to move things
forward in a very real way.
- Well, the podcast is fabulous.
The diversity of your cast,
everyone's gotta be thrilled about that.
- Yeah, it's been a lot of fun,
and a lot of learning and
growth for me as well.
- Great, great.
- Well, as my listeners know,
they're anticipating this.
I always just like to check in with people
and see how people are doing
just in the midst of everything
that we're experiencing.
Obviously we all have our
personal joys and challenges
that we walk through
on a day-to-day basis,
but at this point in
time, October of 2022,
we also have elections that
are coming up in the US,
all the tensions around that.
There are obviously things
that are continuing to go on
all over the world in Russia and Ukraine,
the challenges that have
come up in Iran recently
with some of the women's rights issues
that we're still trying to
see if things will change
for Brittney Griner coming
back to the country,
obviously, just to name a few.
But I always just like
to put things in context
and just see how you're
navigating on a day-to-day basis
with all things personally in your life,
and just where we're on the world stage.
- I think, well, you mentioned Brittney
and she's a fabulous person
and what she did at Baylor
was incredible.
I didn't know her personally,
I don't know her personally,
but she was the reason why
we didn't go to a Final Four
- Yeah.
- She had a three point play
in Memphis that knocked us out.
And Coach K and the guys,
Jon Scheyer and Nolan,
they all went.
And so we made it as far
as Elite Eight together,
but we didn't quite
get to that final four.
- Right, I remember that well.
- Yeah, good times
though, a lot of success.
And getting back to Brittney,
I just keep trying to think
about prayers and thoughts
that she's strong, and I know
this is the biggest challenge
of her life, and I can't imagine.
And the world stage in all
regards is very difficult,
and I just try to focus in my world,
to do what I can for
mental health advocacy
and understanding mental
health impairment,
and trying to motivate
and guide the best I can,
being a non-medical expert,
but just definitely
learning a lot in 27 years.
- That's really well
said, and I appreciate
just walking us through your thoughts
and concern in the midst of the work
that you're doing for Brittney
and that whole situation,
but just also thinking about
how you're making an impact.
And it's interesting for me
to hear you speak as a coach,
I mean, you're not coaching
anymore in that sense,
but to hear how that has translated
into what you're doing now,
and the ways that you're
continuing to coach
in a sense, with a different
or maybe an overlapping mission.
So again, for me, that's
really encouraging.
But before we delve
into that a little bit,
just wanted to have you also
just take our listeners through
your path and how you've got into coaching
in the first place.
And I guess we'll get to touching in
to the way that you're coaching
in society right now too.
But just curious to hear
about your general path.
- Well, I was very
blessed with great mentors
and leadership on all accounts.
I was down at Auburn as
a graduate assistant,
became an assistant coach,
I learned from Joe Ciampi
at Auburn, Pat Summitt,
Sue Gunter, fabulous people.
And I was a head coach at 26
because I'd had the exposure
- Wow.
- Through the Final Four,
National Championship,
became the head coach at 26.
And I read all Coach K's books,
I hadn't met him or anything,
but there weren't as many
books out at that time.
And so I'm a Navy Brat
and he's an army person,
so I was really pulled to that story.
And so that's when I started
studying Mike, and Coach K,
and all of that.
And I had eight years at Maine
and seven at Michigan State,
and that's where I bumped into Tom Izzo,
and we actually did go to
Final Four the same year.
- Right.
- And that was quite
an experience and I learned
a great deal from him.
And working alongside
Coach K for 13 years,
was quite an experience.
And so I've been very gifted,
I've been very fortunate and blessed
to have incredible mentors along the way.
- That's outstanding and great to hear,
was, I'm curious, 26 as a head coach,
was that surprising at that
time, was it an anomaly?
Just thinking back to landscape,
I'm curious what your experience
was like at that point.
- I was, well, at that
time I was the youngest,
I think the youngest ever was
Pat, I think Pat was like 22.
- Wow.
- I admire her greatly,
and I can't believe what she
went through with her brain.
I just, you can't imagine
or even fathom that.
But I think at the time I was the youngest
Division I head coach,
and I was coming home to
Maine, I'm from Maine.
And so that was an enormous
amount of pressure,
to be in your home state.
And some of that pressure
contributed to my, well,
my episode in finding
out that I was in fact
somebody with bipolar disorder.
So I guess there's that awful experience,
but yet at the same time,
I believe in the concept
of the brilliant mind,
and I do believe that if you seek balance,
whatever balance you need to seek,
that you'll be your best ever,
and so many people don't know
that they can get through it.
- Yeah, I think that's really well said.
Definitely something I
want us to come back to
in the conversation as well,
because one of the thing that has come up
on this podcast and just in conversations
is that idea, as you
talked about getting back
to a place of balance,
but the idea of separating mental health
from mental wellness, and this idea
that you don't have to be,
you can have a mental illness
and still have mental wellness.
- Mm, absolutely yeah.
- And at the same time, you
cannot have a mental illness
and not have mental wellness,
in terms of the day-to-day activities,
how people are spending their time.
So really helping us as a
society to think about things
that way, and not to just put
those of us who are struggling
into a specific category of condemnation,
or struggling, or hopelessness,
but to really have that peace.
And that's one of the things
I've really appreciated
with what you've been sharing with folks
as well on this journey.
- Well, it's as you know,
and of course I'm preaching
to the choir here,
but it's a continuum.
And what I feel about the continuum
is it's become much more blurred,
and now whatever was good
for me back in the day,
and I realized bipolar
disorder might be 5%,
I don't know, we don't know
'cause many are undiagnosed,
but let's say five, 4 percent.
The reality is my ability
to relate is a 100%,
with what we've been through.
And so sharing tips and ideas,
whether it's a simple
tip about sleep hygiene,
or something more complicated CBT,
cognitive behavior
therapy, whatever it is,
we're more of a continuum for it,
so I guess that's a good thing.
It's more blended and as you know,
brain health does not discriminate.
I mean, it hits all ages, and
all races, and ethnicities,
and everything.
I think that's the thing, actually,
that is a great example to
many other things in our world.
- Yeah.
- Is that we have
to come together.
- Yeah.
- It's a human thing,
it's a human element.
And I think that has some irony in it.
- Yeah.
- Given all the segmenting
that's going on and
- Yeah.
- I think that's very sad.
- Yeah, I think there's
a huge opportunity there
and a lot of power as well,
if we keep that human lens on things
and use it as a way to bring us together
towards a common goal,
as much as it can be used
to go the opposite direction as well,
as a way to continue to divide people.
So I think that's really,
really important point
that you brought up as well.
Just to loop back a little bit,
as much as you're willing to share,
if you'd be willing to give
our listeners some insight,
you talked about the mentorship,
about the pressure going
back to your home state
in the first episode,
as much you're willing to
share how that all came about.
'Cause I think it's also
very informative for people
to be able to hear a bit of that journey,
and to have some understanding,
because I think bipolar
is one of those things
that unless someone has walked
with someone through it,
sometimes it's hard for people to grasp
or get a concrete sense of
what that really entails.
- Yeah, it's pretty hard
to diagnose, isn't it?
It's a tough one.
What I can say is I was 30
and it was a year after I had
given birth to my first child,
and we were getting that program,
wanting to go to the highest level,
and all of that, had a lot of pride
in being from Maine, coming back.
The program was sort of
bottomed out at the time,
so it was a wonderful opportunity,
and I took it very seriously,
and so seriously that
I lost a dear friend,
was coaching, and then stopped sleeping.
And I didn't think that was a big deal.
I thought I was getting older,
didn't need as much sleep.
And that actually, it gave
me more time to think,
and work, and do.
And my husband was not aware of,
that I had not had two
or three nights sleep,
I said I didn't sleep well.
And, but he, what does that mean?
- Right.
- Remember this was
27 years ago, there isn't
a thought in the world
about brain health, sleep
hygiene, any of those things,
not in the way it is today.
And so I thought, "Wow, this is good,
I can be really efficient and productive."
And then I think the
fourth or fifth night,
you don't crash you just, as you know,
you mainly accelerates.
And the interesting part about it,
was I was very good in front of my team,
because I was very positive,
I was projecting
championships and great things
for the program, I was
organized and on it,
and if you came to
practice, you would've said,
"Wow, what an enthusiastic,
organized coach."
The positivity was through the roof.
So they were taking that in.
But I was fortunate, it
was sort of over a weekend,
I believe, where my husband
and a couple of other friends
recognized that I was losing reality.
And the biggest part that is in my trailer
is I'm talking to a recruit on the phone,
and I tell her that TD's talking to us,
talking to me and to her,
and this is on my trailer,
which I present when I speak.
And she was a great kid and
chose the University of Main
which is an interesting caveat.
- Wow, yeah.
- And she said,
"What do you mean Coach P?"
I said, "No, I'm telling you,
it's telling us great things."
And before I could get
into a long conversation,
John grabbed the phone and he said,
"Jamie, Coach P is just
having a moment here."
- Wow.
- "And we'll call you back."
And so that's how that started.
And then my husband had
to trick me, so to speak,
that we were going for a drive
to take me to a hospital.
And then I deducted, "Oh, there's
something wrong with him."
So in my weird paranoia,
I started to think about,
"Wow, what's wrong with him?"
So I happily went to this
psychiatric hospital, I said,
"Boy, we have to take care of him."
And the reality didn't hit
me until they shut the door.
It's done differently now.
But the way what I had to go through
was a little bit different.
- Yeah.
- And it was like a one
floor over the Cuckoo's Nest
kind of thing.
And I was, the door is shut.
And then I realized I couldn't get out.
And so that's, there's this
whole scene in the book
that I cover about being locked in,
and I run around trying to get out,
and they had to tackle me, and the shots,
and the whole thing.
And so I try to, things
have come a long way
and we should be very proud of that
- Yeah.
- Of where it's come.
And so that was my first episode.
And then just very
quickly, my second episode
was only because I stopped taking my meds,
because I thought I was better.
I'm an athlete, didn't
wanna take any medicine.
And my doctor said, "If you do that
you probably will struggle at the time
you don't wanna struggle the most."
And I didn't believe that,
but sure enough, in February,
in the middle of the season,
I had a depressive episode.
And most people think a depressive episode
is feeling way down.
But it's also, you can't read
the newspaper, as you know,
you can't function, I
couldn't write up a play,
it just was not happening for me.
And then I couldn't coach
in a game, my jaw locked up,
I had allergic reaction.
And long story is I had
to bring this team in
and tell them that I had let them down,
and that I hadn't taken care of myself.
And after that, when I did
that, and the good news is,
we won a championship that
year, we did lose that game
- Right.
- By 30 points,
and because the women knew
something was wrong with me.
- Yeah.
- So that was my story then.
I've had a third episode,
and ironically that
was after leaving Duke,
after getting out of coaching
- Wow.
- Completely.
- I think that's significant
because people think, "Oh,
it's all this pressure
that forces these things."
And if that's the case, I
do have one example of that,
my first episode, but my
third, I was on vacation.
Different story.
- Yeah.
- And so I think it's
important to recognize
the complicated nature of it all.
- Yeah, yeah.
Wow, that was really well said.
And I mean again, just
appreciate your level
of candor and so many important lessons
that you even just talked through,
in talking through your experience.
I mean, thinking about
the way that your husband,
that family stepped in and
was looking out for you,
and paying attention.
I mean, that's such a key
point for those who are
willing and able to
actually notice differences,
and then to be proactive and
help you navigate through that.
But then also just even on your part,
just the humbling experience
that must have been,
even as the realization was
coming along different ways,
as you talked about your first experience
at the hospital, or things
that have happened since then,
the aspects of resilience
that you had to show.
But then also just navigating,
knowing how to navigate,
having one experience
not taking medication,
how that impacted you.
So, I mean, so many important
lessons that you just shared,
even in just walking us
through that so candidly,
which I think is important.
And then even that last example
about the vacation, again,
just the complexity of these challenges,
and that it's not always predictable,
not what people may think.
So I appreciate you taking through that.
And for those who haven't heard
or have that concrete aspect,
I think it's just really helpful
to even hear what that looks like.
'Cause in so many situations
like you mentioned with the coaching,
the mental side is hard
for people to grasp
because it looks so
productive in a lot of ways.
- Yeah it is, yeah it does,
and it feels that way.
And what's really marked by
my experience is a death.
If you go back to my first experience,
it was the pressure of being a coach,
and it was the death of a
dear friend and supporter.,
and all of that went in a direction.
And the timelines aren't always clear
as you reflect backwards,
and then interestingly upon
leaving Duke in July of 2020,
my episode does not
occur until June of 21.
And, but yet I have a cancer
scare, I have a hysterectomy,
and then October 18th, which
is today, this is two years,
my father passed.
So I had my father passing
and I sort of made it through,
I made it along all these responsibilities
and different things going on.
And then I was going up to
Michigan and on vacation,
and it was the human connection
piece that was costing me.
I had lost a lot of
supporters that loved me
because I was with Duke.
Well, I wasn't with Duke anymore.
- Yeah.
- And that's not being
negative towards people,
that's human nature.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I wasn't associated
with Duke, and so my commonality
wasn't there as much.
Your circle gets a little smaller.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I had a dear friend
really step away, that I
thought was a mentor for me.
And so human connection broke.
- Yeah.
- And when that broke,
that was interesting.
And then again, I was in
a psychiatric hospital,
Munson in northern
Michigan by Traverse City.
But what I will say to go
full circle on the story,
is the care that I received there
versus the 26 years
ago, was extraordinary.
- Wow.
- It was.
I mean, I could actually
be cognizant of that,
- Yeah.
- in my journey.
- Yeah, yeah.
So important, I mean,
just another thread of community
that's coming through as well too.
Just the positive aspects of community,
but also what happens
when community is lost.
Because in a sense,
it almost sounds like
maybe this is too far,
but you are going through,
I'm not being clinical here,
but almost a mourning process
of losing some connections,
and re-navigating.
And that's something we talk about a lot,
not something I've booked
to in terms of bipolar,
but just the importance
of community in general
with mental health, how
it can be protective,
how it can help people navigate.
So all those shifts in
community, losing your father,
which I'm sorry to hear about as well.
But all those aspects too,
which are foundational,
and which can also add a level of stress.
So again, I know you said you're speaking
as a non-clinician, but
I think it's so helpful
the ways that you're pulling
on all these different pieces
and how they've impacted you.
'Cause I think that's just
helpful for listeners to hear,
as they or their loved ones
maybe going through things,
and thinking about how those things,
and shifts, and moves can
actually have impacts.
Sometimes in ways that I think people
don't want to necessarily
acknowledge right away,
for fear of maybe appearing
weak, or not strong enough,
but they all have impacts.
And again, me speaking
as a neuroscientist,
knowing that those things
have impacts on our brains,
and how we navigate.
So, I mean, I just appreciate in the way
that you're articulating
that, and talking through it,
and giving life to it
in a way that I think will be life giving
to people who are listening as well.
- Well, I hope so.
And I think that I've always
lived deeply, feel deeply.
There's a wonderful, I guess
that's a wonderful thing,
but you add that to rumination,
and you add that to loss and grieving,
and not to mention my hormonal changes.
I was no longer going to have children,
but that's emptying out.
- Yeah.
I mean, that is everything goes
- And that's
a very strange dynamic.
And the other thing that,
again, not being a doctor,
but it's interesting that a
hormonal shift, a big one,
led to a third episode.
- Yeah.
- And a hormonal shift of birth
led to an episode at almost
exactly the same months
- Wow.
- apart.
- Yeah.
- And 26 years,
so I think it's an interesting story.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And the blessing in it
the third episode, I was
actually in the hospital
for 12 days, it was bad.
My first episode, I was
just in a couple nights
- Okay.
- And I was working with
the team in two weeks.
- Wow.
- So we didn't lose a
beat, I didn't miss a game,
just kept on moving.
But this one was a little
bit more complicated,
and you couldn't have never told me
that it could ever happen.
As a matter of fact, I
said to my family, I said,
"I don't even know if I'm
really have bipolar disorder,
because I haven't had
an episode in 24 years."
I mean, not at Michigan
State, not at Duke.
Just how could, I thought, "Wow."
And I guess the blessing was maybe
this is what I was supposed to do,
learn about my brain
just a little bit more.
- Yeah.
- And then go into this life.
- Yeah, I mean, that is an interesting way
to think about it too.
I know you talked about
being a person to faith.
Not to say that the episode happening
was ordained per se, but even
in a way that it seems like
as you were launching into this mode,
it's also facilitating
what you're talking about,
and even bringing a deeper
level of understanding.
And again, so many scientific
ideas are coming to mind
even as you talk about
other hormonal changes, things like that.
Because something that people
are looking at actively
just in the way that
the hormones interact,
and act in our brains,
and how the interaction,
how it impacts cognition
and mental health,
so there's so many different layers there.
Again, I'm just impressed at your insight
and your introspection,
to be able to know those
things as well, so.
- It's interesting.
- Yeah.
Not to fast forward too fast,
but to jump ahead a little bit
and just also to talk about
how that aspect of your
journey is impacting
what you're doing now.
But I guess before we
get there, I'm curious,
how did it impact you as a coach after
you came to this realization
of having bipolar,
navigating it, having the treatment,
stopping the medication, going back on.
How did that impact you on a daily basis,
and even your perspective of
yourself and of your teams?
- Yeah, so that's a long
answer in a way too,
when I was 26, 27, 28,
29, I was the toughest,
most unreasonable coach you could,
this is back in the day, okay,
this is where discipline was everything.
When I was diagnosed at 30,
I became a better person and
the best coach I had ever been.
- Wow.
- And we won,
now we won before I was diagnosed,
and we won after I was diagnosed.
Championships beat Stanford
and the SWL tournament,
all these things.
But the difference was my relatability,
which I became more intuitive,
I became more clear about my surroundings
and what's around me,
as I worked to make sure
I took care of myself
and my child at the time,
'cause my second child was born later.
And I think that when I
went to Michigan State,
I was truly in my best self.
- Wow.
- I didn't even have
a psych in the state, I worked
out of my psych in Maine,
I would see her once a year.
- Wow.
- And we would connect
and I would do my lithium
levels and things like that,
and I didn't have a therapist or anything.
We were just moving along and played for
a National Championship in five years.
And I used that cycle because
that's a pretty quick way
to get to a national title game.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was recruited by Duke,
I went to Northwestern, but loved Duke.
And so when I was
recruited by Duke to coach,
it was sort of like, "Wow,
what an opportunity."
And Gail had done such
a tough job, I mean,
an incredible job.
And what I mean by tough,
it was tough to follow
such a legend.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But the way I saw it was,
perhaps I could be some
kind of difference maker.
Many people told me not to take the job.
- Wow.
- 'Cause there was
no movement upwards, basically.
I mean, it was National
Championship or forget it.
And I thought that was cool, it's like,
"This is gonna be great."
And when I got to Duke,
I just loved the team,
there was wonderful talent,
we developed wonderful talent,
we we inherited wonderful talent,
we went to the four straight Elite Eights.
It was very hard to break through,
we lost Maya Moore to Connecticut,
We lost Brittney Griner,
so breaking through the Final Four
proved to be very difficult.
And we recruited some great players,
Chelsea Gray, and Haley
Gorecki, and all those.
And, but we played at the highest level.
- Yeah.
- And it was so exciting.
It was met with so many challenges,
I just can't even tell you,
I mean, for so many
reasons that make sense.
It wasn't a rebuild, and I
was still at my best self.
And I think the thing that
people may not understand is,
as a demanding coach,
you have your moments
often in the locker room
at halftime, maybe after
a game, yes that too,
in practice closed doors,
but I was my best self.
And you have great
relationships with players,
and you have some that are not so hot,
where you don't connect,
and that's always sad
because you remember those.
- Yeah.
- Sometimes more than the
ones that you do connect.
- Yeah.
- But yet, I also had to
tackle a player with a panic attack,
but see, I recognized that,
I had education about it.
- Yeah.
- And I wanted
support from our team,
I wanted quick access
to psychiatry if needed.
And so I pushed the
envelope a little bit there,
and we did different things,
hiring a strength coach
and all these things.
But I will say that I was very fortunate
to have some great years coaching,
and maintain balance by
basically being a boring person.
To routine, for family.
- Yeah.
- Having a dog, all these things in place.
And that's why I worry about young people
that don't have all these mechanisms.
You can really fight
through for your children,
of course for your partner or
spouse, but it's not the same.
I mean, it's your children
and you've got to step up
and really stay with your routine,
your swimming or whatever it is.
And, but I think of young people today,
what if they don't have those connectors,
and they're not old enough to understand.
I mean, I was 30 when diagnosed,
and it just, it drives
me a lot to think about
the loneliness that they feel,
because I have definitely been there.
- Yeah, so well said.
I mean, I'm still just processing
all the different pieces
that you've pulled out
getting to this last point,
of just the impact, and
thinking about young people,
and those that you've navigated with,
and coached, and mentored the way
that you were intuitive to it.
But even something you said
early on about how this made you
a better coach and a better person.
Because some may have assumed
that the way you characterize
being disciplinary before
was the most effective.
But sounds like there was
another layer on top of that,
that you're really able to tap
into that carried you through
with all these different aspects.
And just, again, I guess I'm going back
to the community again.
It seemed like it enhanced
that aspect of community,
and the ways that you
engaged in community,
just in terms of perspective.
- Yes, and you can trust
again, after all the sadness,
trust is a big issue.
And not just trusting yourself,
but trusting your players.
It's no secret that we
end up beating Stanford
after I'm on meds, right?
We do something incredible
because there's trust,
and there's a balance of energy.
Of course I yelled at that team,
of course I got upset at the team,
but there was an overall respect and care.
And again, through that journey
at Michigan State and Duke,
there's definitely been
that respect and care.
But the trust factor changes
when you become diagnosed,
when you can trust your doctors,
or listen to your doctors,
don't go it alone.
Now, I will say that the minute you think
you can do it alone, that's
exactly the time not to.
And I just can't stress that enough.
- Yeah, yeah, that's really,
really important advice.
And I think that's something
that people need to hear,
and need to hear over and over again.
Because in the moment, that
tension will definitely
come back, in terms of
trying to navigate alone,
and to hear someone who
has walked through it,
and just to know the
importance of staying connected
and building that trust,
I think is critical.
I'm also curious, I guess I'm
gonna expand on a trust idea
a little bit, and even make
it bigger to a societal sense.
Because part of your
story is also the aspect
of being diagnosed early on,
but not sharing it broadly,
and the counsel that you got
versus what we're seeing now
with a lot of people
who are being more open
about that earlier on to encourage others.
But it's still challenging,
it's still something for
people to walk through.
Where do you think we are as a society
in terms of that trust?
Are we giving people the
space to walk on that?
Or is it just lip service and,
I don't know the best way to put it.
- Yeah, I understand.
- Glossing over in a sense,
and when it comes down to
how we really treat people,
are we really, I guess, are we really
locking authentic trust, or just a facade?
I know that's a way to, not
to put all that on you, but.
- Well, it's a selective
space that we're allowed in.
Upon going public after leaving Duke,
I actually had a blog somewhere say,
"How dare I could not
share that publicly."
I was shamed for not sharing.
And the thing about it is,
is that when I was given
the advice by a doctor,
the advice was extremely
important because it was said,
and I believe this, that it
would've all been about me.
I would be in a press conference
if I had gotten upset,
usually in games, I was pretty,
on the sidelines were
in the bunker together,
so practices were, I was
tougher in practice, right?
You did practices
tougher than in the game.
- Yep.
- But still it would've
taken away from them,
they would ask questions,
I would've been studied and looked at.
- Yeah.
- And of course the
negative recruiting
would've been incredible.
- Yeah.
- So I think the answer
is in selective spaces, people
can, if they're ready, share,
but many times people still cannot share.
And people said, "Would
you go back to coaching?"
I wouldn't change what I'm
doing, I do not take a salary,
I'm raising money for a foundation,
I have been working as
hard as I've ever worked,
but I do pick my spots.
- Yeah.
- Which is nice, and set my own schedule.
- I used to have
a nice salary once upon a time.
Not when I started in coaching,
but later in coaching.
- Right.
- And so I do set my schedule,
and it's wonderful, and it's coaching
lots and lots of people.
But if I wanted to go back
into coaching basketball,
I don't think I could, because
it would take a visionary,
it would take an athletic director
that wasn't always
looking over his shoulder,
which most of them do.
And I love athletic directors,
I've worked for many fabulous ones.
But I have to say, it's
getting a little bit plastic
in regard to Teflon,
everything bounces off,
everything bounces off of people,
everyone's actually operating from fear.
And so I don't think I would be hired back
even if I wanted that to be the case.
- Yeah, and that's
really poignant as well.
I mean, and I think to your
point, that fear is there,
I'm assuming you're talking about even
without thinking about
the mental health aspect
And so you add.
- Yeah, I mean, I think.
- later on in navigating, you know?
- I just think that as a woman,
I am not a bipolar coach,
I'm a coach with bipolar disorder.
- Exactly, yeah.
- And that's
a big distinction.
- Yeah, it's huge.
- And frankly, I'm the
best coach I've ever been,
right now at 57, coaching every human
that is in front of me, or
giving me the opportunity.
And I say coaching
because I'm not a doctor,
I'm not a therapist.
I know a lot about CBT
because it was used with me.
- Right, right.
- Well, I mean,
I paid attention and I've studied,
I've studied this whole,
these dynamics of depression,
anxiety, and how it manifests,
and what the value of my
swim is five times a week,
and all those things.
So I have some referent power that I think
could be very helpful.
- Yeah, I totally agree.
And to follow up on that,
so what is maybe not a daily schedule,
but what is the day-to-day
look like for you?
How are you doing that
coaching at this point
and integrating?
I mean, as we're talking,
I'm thinking integrating
your coaching knowledge,
your basketball knowledge,
just your insights into mental health,
to this full onset of tools
that you can give people?
- Well, it's interesting,
I used to have my schedule set for me.
- Yep.
- And seven days a week,
it's one of our objectives,
24/7, you know the drill.
Okay, so that was that.
Now I have to make sure and
be more diligent than ever
in creating my own schedule.
That free time and idle
time leads to ruminating,
and with a depressed person,
with an anxious person,
with someone with bipolar disorder,
and a person having a bad day.
- Yeah.
- And so,
scheduling my morning
time, my writing time,
my devotional time, that can't be missed.
And initially I was missing
that because I used to get up
at 05:30 in the morning to have that time.
And then of course I stopped getting up
at 05:30 in the morning,
but then I would roll through the morning,
and then I didn't do any of
my thinking or my writing.
- Wow.
- And it took me a while
to come back to that.
So, wait a minute, Joanne,
this is part of who you are.
- Yeah.
- And so you schedule the days
you schedule things, and you
spend time with the flowers,
and you schedule time
though to stay very busy.
And my swim is five or six days a week,
it's non negotiable.
I'm a member of The Y,
I swim wherever I speak.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- That's, yeah.
- I can do that day of talk,
that's really important.
But my weightlifting is not for vanity,
although I like that I'm
in shape, that's good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, that's a very good,
oh gosh, not only for
bones, but for your mind,
that's a good one.
- Yeah.
- And I talk about water therapy a lot,
bathing and sweat is water,
that is really important,
and eating, eating at
roughly the same times,
taking care of yourself.
I don't even eat after
7:30, and people say,
"Well that's interesting."
I said, "Well, I don't feel like it,
my body doesn't like it, and
it's a healthier way to live."
- Yeah.
- And so, it's not
a pious thing, you learn this works.
- Yeah.
- Walking the dog every day,
that's a really good thing.
- Yeah.
- Not to mention the dog liking it.
- So it's not rocket science,
but it is discipline, and
it is awareness to yourself.
- Yeah.
- And if you're
not sleeping well, you
need to pay attention.
- Yeah.
- And make time for that
because it's critically important,
and obviously I've learned all this,
and if I could give
this wisdom to whomever,
and just cut short their
learning curve just a little bit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I wouldn't want
people to have to go
through what I went through,
if you can help them.
- Yeah, and I appreciate hearing,
I mean, it's so clear how your
passion is spilling through
and everything you do,
even as you're sharing
all these tips, even before
you said to help others,
I mean, I could just sense
that you really want others
to be able to get this,
so they can put these things in place
and really have that full
life as you talked about too.
And the importance of all those routines
that you've mentioned, the dog walking,
that's its own interesting aspect itself.
So we had a couple of guests
who came on and talked about
social bonding and oxytocin
that's released in our brain,
there's some really
interesting studies actually
about people and dog interactions,
and how that also facilitates oxytocin.
And so even what you're
talking about just taps into
a lot of those aspects of how it's good
for us and for our brains in general.
And just all the things you mentioned.
I'm gonna put a shameless
plug in here as well,
because my dad actually
joined for one of the episodes
'cause he's a sleep physician,
and just talked about
so many specific aspects
of sleep hygiene, that you talked about.
All the impacts that it
has on mental health,
and ways we can adjust and
notice things that arise.
So, I mean, everything
that you've mentioned
just resonates in so many ways,
and I'm so glad that you're sharing that
with others as well.
- Wow, you come from quite a family.
- I agree.
- You guys are pretty smart.
I dunno, that's pretty smart stuff,
getting through all that
Orgo, I'm impressed.
- I had good role models.
- Yeah.
- But as I've shared in
some other instances,
it took me a minute to incorporate
that into my own story.
So that's a whole other story itself,
in terms of the, what should we call it?
The factor of putting myself
into it versus the laziness.
So that was a journey as well.
But yeah, definitely have great examples
from both of my parents,
both from opportunities,
they both grew up in Ghana, West Africa,
but then also from
their faith perspective,
and just the opportunities
they created for us,
and letting us come to that
space of learning to navigate.
So in a lot of ways it ties in
with the things that you've talked about,
when you think about your children
and how we pass those things along,
but also create those opportunities.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, yeah.
I know it's a tangent,
but I had to go there
'cause you brought it up.
- Oh, it's okay,
that's a great story.
I bet it would be an amazing book.
- Well, I appreciate that, and I shouldn't
give away too many secrets,
but listeners don't know,
but I am actually thinking
about book projects,
so since you mentioned that,
- Good.
- I'll just throw that out there and say
there are things in the works.
- Good.
- But I'm gonna pull now,
my neuroscience is coming back in because
it's so helpful to hear you talk about
all these practical tips,
and I always think about
how it impacts the brain.
I try not to be too centric
on the brain, but again,
that's my expertise in the area of work.
But I know that you have also
talked about the importance
of how we have to be able to understand
the power of our brains.
And so I'm curious what
you mean when you say that,
and how you navigate
that when you're sharing
with audiences or individuals as well.
- Well I think that a balanced brain
is the smartest brain
the brain can be, right?
So we're all gonna work for balance,
and we all have different
journeys to that balance.
And for me, I've had to
negotiate through my life,
again, being an athlete,
I didn't want any foreign
substance in my body,
and I knew I could overcome anything.
I've had to adjust, I've
had to learn to listen,
I've been on lithium since the first day
I was diagnosed to now,
I'm a big lithium advocate.
I know that everyone cannot take it,
I feel sad for that.
I feel like lithium is the
best drug and as you know,
founded ears, I mean, many moons ago.
I had to learn about Lamictal,
another powerful medicine.
And I am a lithium Lamictal person,
and they have played off each other.
And I even gave birth to a
son while taking lithium,
and there's very little research
- Yeah.
- Done on that.
And that was obviously a different
time and a long time ago,
he was born in 2000.
And so, I feel like then I've understood
what Klonopin can do.
Certain things I don't
like, certain drugs,
Restoral is not my favorite.
I could not do a commercial for Restoral,
the addictive quality of
it, and getting off of it,
and the headaches.
And I'm talking for me,
I'm not talking to a
listener out there who says,
"Wow, that works great for me."
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's all very independent
and that's, but you have to
be a scientist to some degree.
You have to study,
you have to wonder how
these things can affect you.
There have been times, I
had kidney complications
because of lithium, there
was a pullback on lithium,
but then that was premature
my kidney gentrified
in a way that didn't make a
whole lot of sense to medicine.
So I've had some
interesting complications,
and I just think that if we're
going to know our brains,
you have to study all facets of it,
and recognize that alcohol
is something I can do
in very small moderation.
But let's face it, I
don't need to be drinking
while I'm taking some
of these medications.
And I can tell you that Zyprexa
is a mind numbing experience
that actually became
necessary for me, at one time.
I couldn't believe the power of that drug.
I love gabapentin, okay, all time favorite
just because of it's
nonaddictive qualities,
help to sleep.
And then Klonopin is an all time favorite
because it works quickly
and you can feel that,
you can feel your chest.
Anxiety is something I've
had leaving coaching,
I've had more anxiety leaving coaching,
than I did coaching in front of 30,000.
- Wow.
- It's really from nothing.
- There's more unknown
there, I would say, than what
- Yeah, yeah.
- than what you were doing.
- So Klonopin can be good.
And I just throw those out there
because you might have listeners
that are having to work
with these medicines.
But you have to be your advocate,
you have to be educated.
And when I talk with
people, they're saying,
"Well, I really don't
know how much I take."
I'm like, "Okay, wait a minute."
- Yeah.
- "Go get your bottles,
are you kidding, you need
to know what you're taking,
how much, and again, you can't
read though on the internet,
all these things."
- Yeah.
- It's crazy how much, all
these things that they say.
So you stick with your doctors,
and you try to test them,
and learn from them.
And so I guess your question was about,
how we maximize our brain health,
and how we become educated about it.
And I do talk to folks
that have bipolar disorder,
and I do remind them that Van Gogh,
and others of great prowess,
were known to have bipolar disorder.
And I do tell them that that
means you have a brilliant mind
except you have to find
your way through the maze.
- Yeah.
- To get there.
- Yeah, wow.
That's so well said, that's so well said.
- And I once had athletic
director tell me,
best compliment I ever got wasn't,
"Oh, you won all these games?"
I had an AD and I love him, he
said, "You are super smart."
And I said, "Yes."
- Yeah.
- And I can say that because
I've been going through
the maze.
- Yeah.
And just when I thought I
had the maze figured out,
- Yeah.
- I was given a much more
sophisticated maze.
- Yeah, yeah, highly agree.
And it just makes me think about,
I mean there's scripture
pastors about being tested,
not being tested beyond what we can bare.
And even just hearing that in your story,
and the way that you talked
about all those pieces,
as you got to a certain
level of understanding,
as you're sharing that with others,
and then another twist
comes along the way.
But I mean, just.
- Yeah.
- Well the faith thing,
I do wanna interject because
I feel so comfortable
when I'm around people faith,
'cause it's really important to me.
And I started with John 14:27,
and this is all about fear.
Do not let your heart
troubled, or let it be afraid.
And I feel like my whole
life, for most of it,
I've been afraid, and
scared about so many things
I had to go through.
- Wow.
- And then as I transitioned Esther 4:14,
such a time as this, New
Testament, Old Testament,
a coming together.
And I realized that these
tattoos where I got them over 50,
and I actually think that's a good idea.
- Wow.
- If you're gonna get a tattoo
wait till you're 50
because then you'll know
what you wanna put on your body.
- That's true, you've had a
lot of time to think about it.
- Right, and then when
I have my tough moments,
I do this.
- Wow.
- It's a form of this.
- Yep.
- Like this.
- Wow.
- And for me, that has
been extremely, and Esther,
the book of Esther is extraordinary to me,
because she does everything she can,
and I feel like a lot of
women or men for that matter,
but a lot of could
relate to the sacrifice,
and her savvy, and her intelligence,
for what she's accomplished.
- Yeah, yeah, that's so, and I appreciate
your willingness and comfort
in sharing that as well,
because I think that's so important,
been such an important part of your story.
And it's a lot of what we've talked about
on this podcast as well,
just the the power of faith
and what God allows us
to navigate in through
these different situations,
and to make sure that that's
an integrated conversation.
Because in too many instances,
just in conversations
that I've had with people,
where people are trying
to separate those things.
So, I mean, that's something
that's just coming through
in your story, even as you
talked about the medications,
as you talked about the fear
that you had to navigate,
and that you were acknowledging,
spending time doing your
devotions in the morning,
and just all these different aspects.
It seems like it's an
ongoing learning experience,
and that's been the power.
I mean, even as you were
sharing about all those aspects,
and I hope the listeners caught that too,
about the mindset shift
that you had about,
not wanting to put any
medications in your body,
to knowing that we do have these tools
that can impact our brains
and help us navigate.
- Yeah.
- But that we also
have the tools that we
can meditate on scripture
that can also help us navigate.
And again, my neuroscience again,
all those things impact our brains.
And so I often feel like
these are all the tools
that God's given us to
be able to move through
and walk through these situations.
So it's actually beautiful
to hear you say that,
and to,
- Wait a minute,
what's beautiful, wait,
what's beautiful is
that you're in academia,
at an Ivy League institution,
being able to express the
merging of all of these things.
And I went to Northwestern so I know what
these worlds are like.
And many times faith is so pushed aside,
and I just do not understand how,
everyone has their thing, right?
So you're proudly karma, whatever it is,
okay whatever you have, use it.
But wisdom is gotta be part of it.
Okay so, I get my wisdom from
the Bible, Psalm or Proverbs.
Okay, that's where I get my wisdom.
But where do you get your wisdom?
I always joke I'm a Buddhist Christian.
(Joanne and Addy laughing)
- I dunno if I've heard that before.
- Yeah, sometimes I do.
- That's funny.
- 'cause in reading about things,
- Yeah.
- And I often do not talk
about my faith, and I've been told
not to talk about my faith,
if I don't have the right audience.
And one of my things I'm
looking forward to someday,
is to get on the stage of a
church and really let it go.
Like, I don't know what I
would say at that point,
but you just feel like
you'd be in a safe space.
So I seldom bring faith into it.
Although in "Secret
Warrior", the book, I do,
I have a chapter on faith because the way
I come around to faith is almost comical.
It's baptized over 50.
- Wow.
- Yeah, so it's funny to me.
- Yeah.
- That's the way things happen sometimes.
- Yeah, well I look forward to
reading through and actually,
I mean, I always encouraged
listeners to listen to,
or read through different
products and books
that our guests have as well.
But I mean, to your point, I think that's,
it's been a positive shift over time.
So I know I keep looping back to my dad,
but when he was on the episode as well,
one of the things that he
shared was just the fact
that we were having the
conversation that we were having,
on this podcast that has
published, broadcast by Yale
in the public space and how
he would not have seen
those things 30 years ago,
when he was training in psychiatry.
And the way this shift has come,
and then others who have
come on the podcast as well,
and just talked about the importance
of not dismissing people.
And I mean that's been
one of our themes too,
to just think about how we
approach mental health in general
and not be dismissive of any one approach.
But that includes whether
someone has a faith background
or not, not dismissing an
aspect that is so central
to who somebody is.
And so, I mean, for me,
I did do some training with
some clinical psychology interns
in New York, and it was encouraging
to see the way the field has shifted.
To say, "Okay, we need
to actually understand
people's life's experiences,
if we're trying to meet
them where they are."
We can't, the old school
idea was that you don't talk
about faith in therapy
or certain taboo topics,
but then how do you ignore a whole aspect
of who somebody is?
And like you said, the
power that comes with that,
and the way that people navigate.
So for me, it's been really encouraging
to be able to step into these spaces,
and then to also see people
be receptive to thinking
about things in a more integrated manner,
in our academic spaces,
in our faith communities.
Because for me and my
listeners have heard me
say this before, to me
it's always distressing
if there's dismission on either side.
So if someone is coming
from a pure scientific lens
and dismisses the power of faith,
or if someone's coming
from a faith perspective,
and dismisses all that
we know about science.
Even as you were talking
about all those effects
those medications have had,
how they've been positive,
we can't ignore that and
pretend it's not there.
So again, my listener is like,
"Oh, he's going off on that again."
But it's a passion and I
have a like-minded individual
here with me, so.
- Yes, very much so.
And you said it extremely well.
And in our world where
there's so much separation,
can we look for commonality?
And if commonality doesn't
match up perfectly,
somebody believes in karma, great.
But just wisdom, can we all agree
that wisdom is a good thing?
And where do you get it?
And I know the way I found it,
I wasn't brought up in any
kind of faith background
whatsoever, so I know
the way I came about,
and we all need to find a
way to come about with it,
with something that gives us wisdom.
- Yeah.
- Because life is
too complicated.
- Yeah.
- You can't do this alone.
- And so I just, oh, I
marvel at what you're saying,
and that gives me great inspiration
for what the reputations are
out there with the ivory tower,
that doesn't relate on many levels.
And then finally, I had a
psychiatrist say to me once,
which was really funny, when
I was having a weaker moment,
he said, "Do you have any faith?
Is there any faith in your background?"
And at the time I did, I
was like, "Well, yeah."
And he said, "Okay, let's review that,
what's that all about?"
So I love
- That's great.
- Talking about the
- Yeah.
- the whole push, pull and
how it can all work together.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
And that's a great segue to
what I wanted to close with too,
because you mentioned the
hope that that gives you,
and I just was gonna have you just share
what gives you hope on a day-to-day basis,
and the place where you
are right now in life.
- Oh gosh, so many things give me hope.
I mean, this podcast, I mean, your work,
and all of your colleagues,
and the direction we're moving.
We haven't arrived, and
of course we never arrive.
And so it's a process,
and we're in this process,
but it's picking up steam,
and the understandings
are becoming more clear.
And I feel I have great faith in people,
and the strength of people,
and I just feel that we're
churning to come together.
It's starting to develop where we realize
that all we have is each other,
and the human experience.
And I think, I feel that,
I know when I speak, and I
speak to different people,
obviously I'm thrilled
if my story can help
just a little bit.
- Yeah.
- And I'm particularly thrilled
when it helps young people.
Those young people that
are just really struggling,
I look at my son, and
losing almost two years
at Northwestern, and the
pain that has caused him.
And this, going back
to school is wonderful,
except they're seeing
what they didn't get.
- Yeah.
- It's sort of, and yes,
we should not look backward, absolutely,
we should be present minded,
but young people can't
always be present minded.
- Yeah.
- So there's a lot
of complicating things
in our world right now,
but I have tremendous faith in humanity.
And I just hope to do my part.
- Well, I think you definitely are.
And I know, I mean, even in
this hour that we've had,
just the things that you share,
I know are definitely you doing your part
in that way as well.
And I know that this is
really gonna be encouraging to listeners.
I imagine people go back
and listen to parts again,
a lot of the nuggets and the
wisdom just that you shared
from your experience,
the lessons you learned along the way,
and how important that is
in so many different ways.
So, I definitely think
you're making that impact.
I'm proud to be able to know you,
and have this conversation,
even beyond the Duke part,
although that was the
foundation that entered,
the Duke Mental Health
conglomeration entered into this.
- Duke, Duke, Duke.
- Yeah.
- Duke, Duke, yeah, got
a lot of that going on.
- Yep, yep, yep, which
is why I got excited
when I saw your background.
- I got it.
- Yeah, but again, I
mean, I'm just so grateful
for the worth that you're doing,
and even the way that you just shared
so wisely and candidly in this last hour,
I think it's something that
people will really be able
to hear things that will resonate,
insights that people will have.
And so, I mean, for me,
it's just, it's an hour to
be a facilitator, in a sense,
to just be here and let
people come and share
all these pieces of
knowledge and experience
with our listeners.
So deeply indebted to you
for taking the time, for your investment,
and for what you're continuing to do.
- Thank you, Doc, I love Docs,
I love all Docs, you guys do great work.
And I so appreciate you having me.
(lively music)